The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's get started.
Today we start a brand
new section of 006,
which is hashing.
Hashing is cool.
It is probably the most used
and common and important
data structure and all
of computer science.
It's in, basically, every system
you've ever used, I think.
And in particular,
it's in Python
as part of what makes
Python fun to program in.
And basically, every modern
programming language has it.
So today is about how to
make it actually happen.
So what is it?
It is usually
called a dictionary.
So this is an
abstract data if you
remember that term from
a couple lectures ago.
It's kind of an old term,
not so common anymore,
but it's useful to think about.
So a dictionary is
a data structure,
or it's a thing,
that can store items,
and it can insert items, delete
items and search for items.
So in general, it's going
to be a set of items,
each item has a key.
And you can insert an item,
you can delete an item
from the set, and you can
search for a key, not an item.
And the interesting
part is the search.
I think you know what
insert and delete do.
So there are two outcomes
to this kind of search.
This is what I call
an exact search.
Either you find an item with a
given key, or there isn't one,
and then you just say
key error in Python.
OK.
This is a little
different from what
we could do with
binary search trees.
Binary search trees, if
we didn't find a key,
we could find the next
larger and the next smaller
successor and predecessor.
With dictionaries you're
not allowed to do that,
or you're not able to do that.
And you're just
interested in the question
does the key exist?
And if so, give me the
item with that key.
So we're assuming here that
the items have unique keys,
no two items have the same key.
And one way to
enforce that is when
you insert an item
with an existing key,
it overwrites whatever
key was there.
That's the Python behavior.
So we'll assume that.
Overwrite any existing key.
And so, it's well
defined what search does.
Either there's one
item with that key,
or there's no item
with that key,
and it tells you what
the situation is.
OK.
So one way to solve
dictionaries is
to use a balanced binary
search tree like AVL trees.
And so you can do all of these
operations on log n time.
I mean, you can ignore the
fact that AVL trees give you
more information
when you do a search,
and still does exact search.
So that's one solution, but it
turns out you can do better.
And while last class was about,
well, in the comparison model
the best way to sort is n log
n and the best way to search
is log n.
Then we saw in the
RAM model, where
if you assume your items are
integers we can sort faster,
sometimes we can
sort in linear time.
Today's lecture is about how to
search faster than log n time.
And we're going to get
down to constant time.
No-- basically, no
assumptions except, maybe,
that your keys are integers.
We'll be able to get
down to constant time
with high probability.
It's going to be a
randomized data structure.
It's one of the few instances
of randomization in 006,
but it'll be pretty simple
to analyze, so don't worry.
But we're going to use
some probability today.
Make it a little exciting.
I think you know how
dictionaries work in Python.
In Python it's the
dict data type.
We've used it all
over the place.
The key things you can
do are lookup a key
and-- so this is the
analog of search--
you can set a key to a value.
This is the analog of an insert.
It overwrites
whatever was there.
And what else?
Delete.
So you can delete
a particular key.
OK.
We'll usually use this
notation because it's
more familiar and intuitive.
But the big topic today
is how do you actually
implement these operations
for a dictionary, D?
The one specific thing
about Python dictionaries
is that an item is
basically a pair
of two things, a
key and a value.
And so, in particular,
when you call d.items
you get a whole bunch of ordered
pairs, a key and a value.
And so the key is always--
the key of an item
is always this first part.
So it's well defined.
OK.
So that's Python dictionaries.
So one obvious motivation
for building dictionaries
is you need them in Python.
And in fact, people
use them all the time.
We used them in docdist.
All of the fastest versions of
the document distance problem
used dictionaries for counting
words, how many times each word
occurs in a document, and
for computing inner products,
for finding common words
between two documents.
And it's just it's the
best way to do things,
it's the easiest way to do
things , and the fastest.
As a result, dictionaries are
built into basically every
modern programming language,
Python, Perl, Ruby, JavaScript,
Java, C++, C#.
In modern versions, all have
some version of dictionaries.
And they all run in,
basically, constant time
using the stuff that's in
this lecture and the next two
lectures.
Let's see.
It's also, in, basically,
every database.
There are essentially two kinds
of databases in the world,
there are those
that use hashing,
and there are those
that use search trees.
Sometimes you need one.
Sometimes you need the other.
There are a lot of situations
in databases where you just
need hashing.
So if you've ever
used Berkeley DB,
there's a hash
type of a database.
So if things like, when
you go to Merriam-Webster,
and you look up a
word, how do you
find the definition
of that word?
You use a hash table, you use
a dictionary, I should say.
How do you-- when you
spell check your document,
how do you tell whether a
word is correctly spelled?
You look it up in a dictionary.
If it's not correctly
spelled, how
do you find the closest
related, correct spelling?
You try tweaking
one the letters,
and look it up in a dictionary
and see if it's there.
You do that for all possible
letters, or maybe two letters.
That is a state of the art
way to do spelling correction.
Just keep looking
up in a dictionary.
Because dictionaries
are so fast you
can afford to do things like
trial perturbations of letters.
What else.
In the old days, which
means pre-Google,
every search engine
on the web would
have a dictionary that
says, for given word,
give me all of the documents
containing that word.
Google doesn't do it that
way, but that's another story.
It's less fancy, actually.
Or when you log
into a system, you
type your username and password.
You look in a dictionary
that stores a username
and, associated
with that username,
all the information
of that user.
Every time you log into a
web system, or whatever,
it is going through
a dictionary.
So they're all over the place.
One of the original
applications is
in writing
programming languages.
Some of the first
computer programs
were programming languages,
so you could actually
program them in
a reasonable way.
Whenever you type a variable
name the computer doesn't
really think about
that variable name,
it wants to think about
an address in memory.
And so you've got to
translate that variable name
into a real, physical address
in the machine, or a position
on the stack, or whatever
it is in real life.
In the old days
of Python, I guess
this is pre-Python
2 or so, 2.1, I
don't remember the
exact transition it was.
In the interpreter,
there was the dictionary
of all your global
variables, there's
a dictionary of all
your local variables.
And that was-- it
was right there.
I mean you could
modify the dictionary,
you could do crazy things.
And all the
variables were there.
And so they'd match the
key to the actual value
stored in the variable.
They don't do that anymore
because it's a little slow,
but-- and you could
do better in practice.
But at the very least, when
you're compiling the thing,
you need a dictionary.
And then, later on, you can
do more efficient lookups.
Let's see.
On the internet there
are hash tables all over,
like in your router.
Router needs to know
all the machines that
are connected to it.
Each machine has an IP address,
so when you get a packet in,
and it says, deliver to
this IP address, you see,
oh, is it in my dictionary
of all the machines
that are directly
connected to me?
If so, send it there.
If it's not then it has
to find the right subnet.
That's not quite a
dictionary problem,
a little more complicated.
But for looking up local
machines, it's a dictionary.
Routers use dictionaries because
they need to go really fast.
They're getting a billion
packets every second.
Also, in the network
stack of a machine,
when you come in you
get it packet delivered
to a particular port, you need
to say, oh, which application,
or which socket is
connected to this port?
All of these things
are dictionaries.
The point is they're
in, basically,
everything you've ever
used, virtual memory,
I mean, they're
all over the place.
There are also some more
subtle applications,
where it is not obvious
that's it a dictionary,
but still, we use
this idea of hashing
we're going to talk about today.
Like searching in a string.
So when you hit-- I don't
know-- in your favorite editor,
you do Control-F, or
Control-S, or slash,
or whatever your way of
searching for something
is, and you type start typing.
If your editor is
clever, it will
use hashing in order to
search for that string.
It's a faster way to do it.
If you use grep, for example, in
Unix it does it in a fancy way.
Every time you do
a Google search
it's essentially using this.
It's solving this problem.
I don't know what algorithm,
but we could guess.
Using the algorithms we'll
cover in next lecture.
It wouldn't surprise me.
Also, if you have
a couple strings
and you want to know what they
have in common, how similar
they are?
Example, you have
two DNA strings.
You want to see how similar
they are, you use hashing.
And you're going to do that
in the next problem set, PS4,
which goes out on Thursday.
Also, for things like file
and directory synchronization.
So on Unix, if you rsync
or unison, or, I guess,
modern day-- these
days, Dropbox, MIT
startup-- Whenever you're
synchronizing files between two
locations, you use
hashing to tell
whether a file has changed,
or whether a directory has
changed.
That's a big idea.
Fairly modern idea.
And also in
cryptography-- this will
be a topic of next
Tuesday's lecture.
If you're transferring
a file and you
want to check that you
actually transferred that file,
and there wasn't some person in
the middle corrupting your file
and making it look like it
was what you wanted it to be,
you use something called
cryptographic hash functions,
which [INAUDIBLE] will
talk about on Tuesday.
So tons of motivation
for dictionaries.
Let's actually do it,
see how they are done.
We're going to start with sort
of a very simple straw man,
and then we're going to improve
it until, by the end of today,
we have a really good way
to solve the dictionary
problem in constant
time for operation.
So the really simple approach
is called a direct access table.
So it's just a big
table, an array.
You have-- the index into
the array is the key.
So, store items in an
array, indexed by key.
And in fact, Python kind
makes you think about this
because the Python notation
for accessing dictionaries
is identical to the notation
for accessing arrays.
But with arrays, the
keys are restricted
to be non-negative integers,
0 through n minus 1.
So why not just
implement it that way?
If your keys happen
to be integers
I could just store all my
items in a giant array.
So if I just want to store
an item here with key 2,
call that, maybe, item
2, I just put that there.
If I want to store
something with key 4
I'll just put it there.
Everything else is going to
be null, or none, or whatever.
So lots of blank entries.
Whatever keys I don't use I'll
just put a null value there.
Every key that I want to
put into the dictionary
I'll just store it at the
corresponding position.
What's bad about this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's hard to associate
something with just an integer.
PROFESSOR: Hard to associate
something with an integer.
Good.
That's one problem.
There's actually two big
problems with this structure.
I want both of them.
So bad-- badness number one
is keys may not be integers.
Good.
Another problem.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Possibility
of collision.
PROFESSOR: Possibility
So here there's no collisions.
We'll get to
collisions in a moment,
but a collision
is when two items
go to the same
slot in this table.
And we defined the problem
so there weren't collisions.
We said whenever we insert
item with the same key you
overwrite whatever is there.
So collisions are OK.
They will be a problem in a
moment, so save your answer.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Running time?
PROFESSOR: For deletion?
Actually, running time
is going to be great.
If I want to insert-- I
mean, I do these operations
but on array instead
of a dictionary.
So if I want insert I
just put something there.
If I want to delete I
just set it to null.
If I want to search I just
go there and see is it null?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's a
gigantic memory hog
PROFESSOR: It's
gigantic memory hog.
I like that phrasing.
Not always of course.
If it happens that your keys
are-- the set of possible keys
is not too giant
then life is good.
Let's see If I cannot
kill somebody today.
Oh yes.
Very good.
But if you have a
lot of keys, you
need one slot in
your array per key.
That could be a lot.
Maybe your keys are
64-bit integers.
Then you need 264 slots just
to store one measly dictionary.
That's huge.
I guess there's also the
running time of initialize that.
But at the very least,
you have huge space hog.
This is bad.
So we're going to fix both of
these problems one at a time.
First problem we're
going to talk about
is what if your keys
aren't integers?
Because if your
keys aren't integers
you can't use this at all.
So lets at least get
something that works.
And this is a notion
called prehashing.
I guess different people
call it different things.
Unfortunately Python
calls it hash.
It's not hashing,
it's prehashing.
Emphasized the "pre" here.
So prehash function
maps whatever keys
you have to
non-negative integers.
At this point we're not
worrying about how big
those integers are.
They could be giant.
We're not going to fix the
second problem til later.
First problem is if I have
some key, maybe it's a string,
it's whatever, it's an object,
how do I map it to some integer
so I could, at least
in principle, put it
in a direct access table.
There's a theoretical
answer to how to do this,
and then there's the practical
answer. how to do this.
I'll start with
the mathematical.
In theory, I like this, keys
are finite and discrete.
OK.
We know that anything
on the computer
could, ultimately, be written
down as a string of bits.
So a string of bits
represents an integer.
So we're done.
So in theory, this is easy.
And we're going to
assume in this class,
because it's sort
of a theory class,
that this is what's happening.
At least for
analysis, we're always
going to analyze things as
if this is what's happening.
Now in reality, people
don't always do this.
In particular-- I'll
go somewhere else.
In Python it's not
quite so simple,
but at least you get
to see what's going on.
There's a function called hash,
which should be called prehash,
and it, given an
object, it produces
a non-- I'm not sure,
actually, if it's non-negative.
It's not a big deal if it has
a minus sign because then you
could just use this and
get rid of the sign.
But it maps every
object to an integer,
or every hashable
object, technically.
But pretty much
anything can be mapped
to an integer, one
way or another.
And so for example, if
you given it an integer
it just returns the integer.
So that's pretty easy.
If you give it a string
it does something.
I don't know exactly
what it does,
but there are some issues.
For example, hash of
this string, backslash 0B
is equal to the hash of
backslash 0 backslash 0C 64.
It's a little tricky
to find these examples,
but they're out there.
And I guess, this is
probably the lowest one
in a certain measure.
So it's a concern.
In practice you have to be
careful about these things
because what you'd
like-- in an ideal world,
and in the theoretical world--
this prehash function of x,
if it equals the
prehash function of y,
this should only
happen when x=y,
when they're the same thing.
And equals equal sense, I guess,
would be the technical version.
Sadly, in Python this
is not quite true.
But mostly true.
Let's see.
If you define a custom
object, you may know this,
there is an __hash__
method you can implement,
which tells Python what
to do when you call hash
of your object.
If you don't, it
uses the default
of id, which is the
physical location
of your object in memory.
So as long as your object
isn't moving around in memory
this is a pretty
good hash function
because no two items occupy
the same space in memory.
So that's just implementation
side of things.
Other implementation side
of things is in Python,
well, there's this distinction
between objects and keys,
I guess you would say.
You really don't want
this prehash function
to change value.
In, say, a direct access
table, if you store--
you take an item, you
compute the prehash function
of the key in there, and you
throw it in, and it says,
oh, prehash value is four.
Then you put it
in position four.
If that value change, then when
you go to search for that key,
and you call prehash of that
thing, and if it give you five,
you look in position five, and
you say, oh, it's not there.
So prehash really
should not change.
If you ever implement this
function don't mess with it.
I mean, make sure it's
defined in such a way
that it doesn't
change over time.
Otherwise, you won't be able to
find your items in the table.
Python can't protect
you from that.
This is why, for example,
if you have a list,
which is a mutable object, you
cannot put it into a hash table
as a key value because it
would change over time.
Potentially, you'd append
to the list, or whatever.
All right.
So hopefully you're
reasonably happy with this.
You could also
think of it is we're
going to assume keys are
non-negative integers.
But in practice,
anything you have you
can map to an integer,
one way or another.
The bigger problem
in a certain sense,
or the more interesting
problem is reducing space.
So how do we do that?
This would be hashing.
This is sort of the magic
part of today's lecture.
In case you're
wondering, hashing
has nothing to do with hashish.
Hashish is a Arabic root word
unrelated to the Germanic,
which is hachet, I believe.
Yeah.
Or hacheh-- I guess,
something like that.
I'm not very good at German.
Which means hatchet.
OK
It's like you take your
key, and you cut it up
into little pieces, and you mix
them around and cut and dice,
and it's like cooking.
OK.
What?
AUDIENCE: Hash browns.
PROFESSOR: Hash
browns, for example.
Yeah, same root.
OK.
It's like the only two English
words with that kind of hash.
OK.
In our case, it's
a verb, to hash.
It means to cut into
pieces and mix around.
OK.
That won't really be clear
until towards the end of today's
lecture, but we
will eventually get
to the etymology of hashing.
Or, we've got the etymology,
but why it's, actually,
why we use that term.
All right.
So the big idea is we
take all possible keys
and we want to reduce them
down to some small, small set
of integers.
Let me draw a picture of that.
So we have this giant
space of all possible keys.
We'll call this key space.
It's like outer
space, basically.
It's giant.
And if we stored a
direct access table,
this would also be giant.
And we don't want to do that.
We'd like to somehow map
using a hash function h down
to some smaller set.
How do I want to draw this?
Like an array.
So we're going to have possible
values 0 up to m minus 1.
m is a new thing.
It's going to be the
size of our hash table.
Let's call the hash table.
I think we'll call it t also.
And we'd somehow like to map--
All right.
So there's a giant space
of all possible keys,
but then there's a subset
of keys that are actually
stored in this set,
in this dictionary.
At any moment in
time there's some set
of keys that are present.
That set changes,
but at any moment
there's some keys that
are actually there.
k1, k2, k3, k4.
I'd like to map them to
positions in this table.
So maybe I store k2-- or
actually, item 2 would go here.
In particular, this is when
h of k2, if it equals zero,
then you'd put item 2 there.
Item 3, let's say,
it's at position-- wow,
3 would be a bit of a
coincidence, but what the hell.
Maybe h or k3 equals 3.
Then you'd put item 3 here.
OK.
You get the idea.
So these four items each
have a special position
in their table.
And the idea is we would
like to be, m to be around n.
n is the number of keys In
the dictionary right now.
So if we could achieve
that, the size of the table
was proportional to the
number of keys being stored
in the dictionary, that would
be good news because then
the space is not
gigantic and hoggish.
It would just be linear,
which is optimal.
So if we want to store
m things, maybe we'll
use 2m space, a 3m
space, but not much more.
How the heck are we going
to define such a function h?
Well, that's the
rest of the lecture.
But even before we
define a function h,
do you see any
problems with this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This space over here, this
is pigeonhole principle.
The number of slots for
your pigeons over here
is way smaller than the
number of possible pigeons.
So there are going
to be two keys that
map to the same slot
in the hash table.
This is what we
call a collision.
Let's call this, I
don't know, ki, kj.
h of ki equals h of kj,
but the keys are different.
So ki does not equal kj,
yet their hash functions
are the same, hash
values are the same.
We call that a collision.
And that's guaranteed to
happen a lot, yet somehow,
we can still make this work.
That's the magic.
And that is going
to be chaining.
We've done these guys.
Next up is a technique for
dealing with collisions.
There are two techniques
for dealing with collisions
we're going to
talk about in 006.
One is called chaining,
and next Tuesday, we'll
see another method
called open addressing.
But let's start with chaining.
The idea with chaining a simple.
If you have multiple items
here all with the same-- that
hash to the same position,
just store them as a list.
I'm going to draw
it as a linked list.
I think I need a
big picture here.
So we have our nice universe,
various keys that we actually
have present.
So these are the keys
in the dictionary,
and this is all of key space.
These guys map to
slots in the table.
Some of them might
map to the same value.
So let's say k1 and k2,
suppose they collide.
So they both go this slot.
What we're going to store
here is a linked list
that stores item 1,
and stores a pointer
to the next item,
which is item 2.
And that's the end of the list.
Or you could-- however
you want to draw a null.
So however many items
there are, we're
going to have a linked list
of that length in that slot.
So in particular, if there's
just one item, like say,
this k3 here, maybe it
just maps to this slot.
And maybe that's all
that maps to that slot.
In that case, we just
say, follow this item 3,
and there's no other items.
Some slots are going
to be completely empty.
There nothing there so you
just store a null pointer.
That is hashing with chaining.
It's pretty simple,
very simple really.
The only question is why would
you expect it to be any good?
Because, in the worst case,
if you fix your hash function
here, h, there's going to
be a whole bunch of keys
that all map to the same slot.
And so in the worst case, those
are the keys that you insert,
and they all go here.
And then you have this
fancy data structure.
And in the end, all you have is
a linked list of all n items.
So the worst case is theta n.
And this is going to be true for
any hashing scheme, actually.
In the worst case,
hashing sucks.
Yet in practice, it works
really, really well.
And the reason is
randomization, essentially,
that this hash function,
unless you're really unlucky,
the hash function will
nicely distribute your items,
and most of these lists
will have constant length.
We're going to prove
that under an assumption.
Well have to warm
up a little bit.
But I'm also going to cop
out a little m as you'll see.
So in 006 we're going to make
an assumption called Simple
Uniform Hashing.
OK.
And this is an assumption,
it's an unrealistic assumption.
I would go so far as to say
it's false, a false assumption.
But it's really
convenient for analysis,
and it's going to
make it obvious
why chaining is a good idea.
Sadly, the assumption
isn't quite true,
but it gives you a flavor.
If you want to see why
hashing is actually good,
I'm going to hint at it
at the end of lecture
but really should
take 6.046 Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] question.
Is the hashing
function [INAUDIBLE]?
Like, how do we know the
array is still [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The hashing function-- I guess
I didn't specify up here.
The hashing function maps
your universe to 0, 1,
up to m minus 1,
That's the definition.
So it's guaranteed to reduce the
space of keys to just m slots.
So your hashing function
needs to know what m is.
In reality there's not going
to be one hashing function,
there's going to be 1 for each
m, or at least one for each m.
And so, depending on
how big your table is,
you use the corresponding
hash function.
Yeah, good question.
So the hash function
is what does
the work of reducing
your key space down
to small set of slots.
So that's what's going
to give us low space.
OK.
But now, how do we get low time?
Let me just state this
assumption and get to business.
Simply, uniform hashing
is, essentially,
two probabilistic assumptions.
The first one is uniformity.
If you take some
key in your space
that you want to store
the hash function
maps it to a uniform
random choice.
This is, of course, is
what you want to happen.
Each of these slots here is
equally likely to be hashed to.
OK.
That's a good start.
But to do proper analysis,
not only do we uniformity,
we also need independence.
So not only is this true
for each key individually,
but it's true for all
the keys together.
So if key one maps to
a uniform random place,
no matter where it
goes, key two also
matches to a uniform
random place.
And no matter
where those two go,
key three maps to a
uniform random place.
This really can't be true.
But if it's true, we can prove
that this takes constant time.
So let me do that.
So under this assumption,
we can analyze
hashing-- hashing with chaining
is what this method is called.
So let's do it
I want to know-- I
got to cheat, sorry.
I got to remember the notation.
I don't have any
good notation here.
All right.
What I'd like to know is the
expected length of a chain.
OK.
Now this is if I have n keys
that are stored in the table,
and m slots in the
table, then what
is the expected
length of a chain?
Any suggestions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 1 over m to the n.
PROFESSOR: 1 over m to the n?
That's going to be a
probability of something.
Not quite.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's
between 0 and 1.
It's probably at least
one, or something.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: m over n.
PROFESSOR: n over m, yeah.
It's really easy.
The chance of a key going to
a particular slot is 1 over m.
They're all independent, so
it's 1 over m, plus 1 over m,
plus 1 over m, n times.
So it's n over m.
This is really easy when
you have independence.
Sadly, in the real world,
you don't have independence.
We're going to call
this thing alpha,
and it's also known as the
load factor of the table.
So if it's one, n equals m.
And so the length
of a chain is one.
If it's 10, then you have
10 times as many elements
as you have slots.
But still, the expected
length of a chain is 10.
That's a constant.
It's OK.
If it's a 12, that's OK.
It means that you have a bigger
table than you have items.
As long as it's a constant,
as long as we have-- I
erased it by now-- as
long as m is theta n,
this is going to be constant.
And so we need to
maintain this property.
But as long as you set your
table size to the right value,
to be roughly n, this
will be constant.
And so the running time of
an operation, insert, delete,
and search-- Well,
search is really
the hardest because when you
want to search for a key,
you map it into your table,
then you walk the linked list
and look for the key that
you're searching for.
Now is this the key
you're searching for?
No, it's not the key
you're searching for.
Is this the key
you're searching for?
Those are not the keys
you're searching for.
You keep going.
Either you find your
key or you don't.
But in the worst case, you
have to walk the entire list.
Sorry for the bad Star
Trek reference-- Star Wars.
God.
I'm not awake.
All right.
In general, the running
time, in the worst case,
is 1 plus the length
of your chain.
OK.
So it's going to
be 1 plus alpha.
Why do I write one?
Well, because alpha can be much
smaller than 1, in general.
And you always have
to pay the cost
of computing the hash function.
We're going to assume
that takes constant time.
And then you have to
follow the first pointer.
So you always pay constant time,
but then you also pay alpha.
That's your expected life.
OK.
That's the analysis.
It's super simple.
If you assume Simple
Uniform Hashing,
it's clear, as long as your load
factor is constant, m theta n,
you get constant running
time for all your operations.
Life is good.
This is the intuition
of why hashing works.
It's not really
why hashing works.
But it's about as far as
we're going to get in 006.
I'm going to tell
you a little bit more
about why hashing is actually
good to practice and in theory.
What are we up to?
Last topic is hash functions.
The one remaining thing
is how do I construct h?
How do I actually map from
this giant universe of keys
to this small set of slots in
the table, there's m of them?
I'm going to give you three hash
functions, two of which are,
let's say, common practice, and
the third of which is actually
theoretically good.
So the first two are
not good theoretically.
You can prove that they're
bad, but at least they
give you some
flavor, and they're
still common in practice because
a lot of the time they're OK,
but you can't really
prove much about them.
OK.
So first method, sort
of the obvious one,
called the division method.
And if you have
a key, this could
be a giant key, huge
universe of keys,
you just take that
key, modulo m,
that gives you a number
between zero and m minus 1.
Done.
It's so easy.
I'm not going to
tell you in detail
why this is a bad method.
Maybe you can think about it.
It's especially bad if m has
some common factors with k.
Like, let's say
k is even always,
and m is even also
because you say,
oh, I'd like a table the
size of power of two.
That seems natural.
Then that will be really
bad because you'll
use only half the table.
There are lots of situations
where this is bad.
In practice, it's pretty good.
If m is prime, you always
choose a prime table size,
so you don't have
those common factors.
And it's not very close to
a power of 2 or power of 10
because real world powers
of 2's and 10's are common.
But it's very hackish, OK?
It works a lot of the
time but not always.
A cooler method-- I think
it's cooler-- still,
you can't prove much
about it-- Division didn't
seem to work so great, so
how about multiplication?
What does that mean?
Multiply by m, that
wouldn't be very good.
Now, it's a bit different.
We're going to take the key,
multiply it by an integer, a,
and then we're going to do
this crazy, crazy stuff.
Take it mod 2 to the w and
then shift it right, w minus r.
OK.
What is w?
We're assuming that
we're in a w-bit machine.
Remember way back in
models of computation?
Your machine has a
word size, it's w bits.
So let's suppose it's w bits.
So we have our key, k.
Here it is.
It's w bits long.
We take some number,
a-- think of a as being
a random integer among all
possible w bit integers.
So it's got some zeros,
it's got some ones.
And I multiply these.
What does multiplication
mean in binary?
Well, I take one of these copies
of k for each one that's here.
So I'm going to
take one copy here
because there's a one there.
I'm going to take one copy here
And I'm going to
take one copy here
because there's a one there.
And on average, half
of them will be ones.
So I have various copies of k,
and then I just add them up.
And you know, stuff happens.
I get some gobbledygook here.
OK.
How big is it?
In general, it's two words long.
When I multiply two
words I get two words.
It could be twice
as long, in general.
And what this business is doing
is saying take the right word,
this right half here-- let
the right word in, I guess,
if you see vampire
movies-- and then shift
right-- this is a shift right
operation-- by w minus r.
I didn't even say what r is.
But basically, what
I want is these bits.
I want r bits here--
this is w bits.
I want the leftmost r bits
of the rightmost w bits
because I shift right here
and get rid of all these guys.
r-- I should say,
m, is two to the r.
So I'm going to
assume here I have
a table of size a power of
2, and then this number will
be a number between
0 and m minus 1.
OK.
Why does this work?
It's intuitive.
In practice it works quite
well because what you're
doing is taking a whole
bunch of sort of randomly
shifted copies of k, adding
them up-- you get carries,
things get mixed
up-- This is hashing.
This is-- you're taking
k, sort of cutting it up
while you're shifting it around,
adding things and they collide,
and weird stuff happens.
You sort of randomize stuff.
Out here, you don't
get much randomization
because most-- like
the last bit could just
be this one bit of k.
But in the middle, everybody's
kind of colliding together.
And so intuitively,
you're mixing
lots of things in the center.
You take those r bits,
roughly, in the center.
That will be nicely mixed up.
And most of the time
this works well.
In practice it works well-- I
have some things written here.
a better be odd, otherwise
you're throwing away stuff.
And it should not be very
close to a power of 2.
But it should be in between 2
to the r minus 1 and 2 to the r.
Cool.
One more.
Again, theoretically,
this can be bad.
And I leave it as an exercise
to find situations, find
key values where this
does not do a good job.
The cool method is
called universal hashing.
This is something that's a
bit beyond the scope of 006.
If you want to understand it
better you should take 046.
But I'll give you the flavor and
the method, one of the methods.
There's actually
many ways to do this.
We see a mod m on the outside.
That's just division method just
to make the number between 0
and a minus 1.
Here's our key.
And then there's
these numbers a and b.
These are going to be
random numbers between 0
and p minus 1.
What's p?
Prime number bigger than
the size of the universe.
So it's a big prime number.
I think we know how
to find prime numbers.
We don't know in this
class, but people
know how to find
the prime numbers.
So there's a subroutine
here, find a big prime number
bigger than your universe.
It's not too hard to do that.
We can do it in polynomial time.
That's just set up.
You do that once for
a given size table.
And then you choose two
random numbers, a and b.
And then this is the
hash function, a times k
plus b, mod p mod m.
OK.
What does this do?
It turns out-- here's
the interesting part.
For worst case keys, k1
and k2, that are distinct,
the probability of h of k1
equaling h of k2 is 1 over n.
So probability of two keys
that are different colliding
is 1 over m, for
the worst case keys.
What the heck does that mean?
What's the probability over?
Any suggestions?
What's random here?
AUDIENCE: a and b.
PROFESSOR: a and b.
This is the probability
over a and b.
This is the probability over the
choice of your hash function.
So it's the worst case
inputs, worst case insertions,
but random hash function.
As long as you choose
your random hash function,
the probability of
collision is 1 over m.
This is the ideal situation
And so you can prove, just
like we analyzed here--
It's a little more work.
It's in the notes.
You use linearity
of expectation.
And you can prove, still,
that the expected length
of a chain-- the expected number
of collisions that a key has
with another key is the load
factor, in the worst case,
but in expectation for
a given hash function.
So still, the expected
length of a chain,
and therefore, the
expected running time
of hashing with chaining,
using this hash function,
or this collection of hash
functions, or a randomly chosen
one, is constant for
constant load factor.
And that's why hashing
really works in theory.
We're not going to go into
details of this again.
Take 6.046 if you want to know.
But this should make you
feel more comfortable.
And we'll see other ways
do hashing next class.